il y à une demi heure à peu près un
convoi d'une trentaine de camions
militaires a été bloqué à trois
kilomètres de la place tienanmen bloqués
par des milliers de manifestants des
ouvriers par camions entiers des
étudiants continuent d'affluer vers la
place où les manifestants font la chaîne
et attendent donc les militaires il est
à pékin un peu plus de 3 heures du matin
quelle journée il ya près de 24 heures à
l'aube ce matin le premier ministre et
le secrétaire général du parti
communiste chinois s'était rendu sur la
place et tentait de convaincre les
étudiants d'abandonner la grève de la
faim qu'ils suivent depuis sept jours
georges bortoli nous raconte la journée
la télévision chinoise l'a montré
plusieurs fois chalsa secrétaire général
du parti a rendu visite à 4h40 du matin
aux grévistes de la preuve il leur a
fait un don à ces paternel des
propositions qui restait très ferme
cesser votre grève ils nous tiendrons
compte de vos revendications effets
négatifs une heure plus tôt quand le
soleil sous raids l'occupation de la
place tienanmen par les étudiants
continuent elles continuent tandis que
les balayeurs évacuent les monceaux
d'ordures résultant de six jours
d'occupation aggravée par l'orage qui a
transformé la place en bourbier
les étudiants ont abrité les 300
grévistes de la faim leurs camarades
dans 90 autobus réquisitionnés par la
croix rouge aux effets de la fin de la
déshydratation pour certains s'ajoutent
les dangers de maladie contagieuse causé
par l'absence d'hygiène périodiquement
certains sont évacués vers les hôpitaux
dont la plupart reviennent dès que
possible
une journée d'attenté la 7e commence
alors que tout autour de la place
tiananmen toute la chine vit des heures
d' incroyable confusion les organes
d'information officielle ne cherche même
plus à le cacher un début d'anarchie est
en train de s'installer avec des
manifestations partout des trains qui
n'arrivent plus des usines qui ne
travaillent plus guère
de quoi doper les étudiants n'ont la
plupart semble fatigué fatigué malgré
l'afflux de milliers de jeunes venus de
province sur leurs camarades par la voix
ou par la méditation
c'est peut être pour cela que le soir
venant un leader des étudiants de pékin
demande à tous de faire preuve de
sagesse et conseille même aux grévistes
de la faim de cesser leur grève
bien sûr nous le dit il un peu plus tard
je n'ai qu'un conseil si un seul
continue à faire la grève nous resterons
à ses côtés mais il est raisonnable de
cesser la grève de la faim parce que la
situation n'évolue pas selon la volonté
des étudiants